سننتقل الى القاهره لنقل الاحتفالات الحال
وهذه صور مباشره من القاهره
لدخول العام الجديد هذه الصور احتفاليه من
قلب القاهره ومعنا من هناك مراسلنا تامر
نصرت ينقل لنا صوره من هنا
كل عام وانتم بخير اعتقد انكم اتصلتم في
الوقت المناسب
الاحتفالات بدات في القاهره مع دقات ساعه
هذه النشره بالفعل الثانيه عشر تماما
بالتوقيت المحلي
ونحن هنا في ممشا اهل مصر همم
علينا الاوراق الملونه منذ قليل كان العرض
الالعاب الناريه همم انتهى همم منذ لحظات
انتهى الى توهي همم هناك بضعه الاف هنا
مجتمعون على ممشا اهل مصر وهو يعني واحد
من الاضافات السياحيه همم
البلاد خلال هذا العام همم على مدار على
مسافه ما يقرب من كيلو مترين تقريبا يتجمع
الناس هنا هناك ايضا همم عدد من الاماكن
اخرى في القاهره مثل برج القاهره وكوبري
قصر النيل وغيرها من الاماكن السياحيه
يتجمع عندها بضعه الاف كما اا ربما
تشاهدون الان
وقد يعني ايضا حتى همم عدد من المتابعين
يشاهدون هذا الامر من خلال رحلات المراكب
النيليه الصغيره او الفولوكات على صفحه
هذا النهر الخالد عموما يعني هو عام جديد
يبدا 2023 والجميع جاء الى هنا او يعني
مهند استطاع ان ياتي الى هنا بطبيعه الحال
همم لكي يودع عام كان همم صعبه همم على
الجميع همم حتى ان يعني بعض هذه
الاحتفالات هي احتفالات همم تقيمها مؤسسات
تابعه للدوله تقيمها بالمجان لعدد
الجماهير الاخيره من يريد ان يجتمع في هذه
الاماكن المفتوحه طبعا الجو ليس باردا
كثيرا في القاهره همم هذا المساء ولكن
يعني جو مناسب للاحتفال ربما تكون الظروف
الاقتصاديه غير ذلك ولكن يعني انه يوم
للنسيان او سنه للنسيان ربما همم للكثير
من المصري وفي نفس الوقت همم استبشار او
محاوله التفاؤل نحو العام الجديد
[موسيقى]